Der Rasenfunk. Kurzpasst. Viel zu lange haben wir nicht mehr auf die Serie A geblickt. Das wollen wir jetzt nachholen. Nach 21 gespielten Spieltagen sprechen wir mit Mario Rica von der Saunen über die italienische Liga. Mario, schön, dass du hier bist.
Freut mich auch sehr. Danke für die Einladung.
Ja, es wurde mal wieder Zeit, dich jetzt zu haben. Irgendwann warst du schon mal im Rasenfunk mit dabei. Das ist aber schon eine ganze Weile her. Ich hab's jetzt nicht mehr nachgeguckt.
Ich glaub, wirklich irgendwo noch in der Küche und...
Verrückt. Haben wir uns da auch tatsächlich getroffen?
Nee, das hab ich mit dem Fehlpass verwechselt. Nein, wir haben wirklich auch mal über die Funke sozusagen.
Ja, genau.
Aber ich glaub, da war Werder das Thema.
Ja, da war definitiv Werder das Thema und das könnte sogar noch in den einstelligen Rasenfunk-Zeiten gewesen sein. Jetzt muss ich es doch nachgucken live, um das zu wissen, das war ja am 27.10.2014. Das ist krass. Das ist eine Weile her, das war der neunte Spieltag. Das muss irgendwie Ausgabe Nummer 6 oder so was des Rasenfunks gewesen sein. Und jetzt, keine Ahnung, 350 Folgen später hat es wieder geklappt. Ja, ich bleib halt dann auch irgendwie dran. Und jetzt reden wir über die Serie A und ich hab's schon im Intro gesagt, da warten die Hörerinnen und Hörer jetzt schon viel zu lange drauf. Da haben wir im November irgendwann mal drüber gesprochen. Es gibt allerdings so ein paar Konstanten, die gleich geblieben sind und die eine davon ist Juve. Die haben nämlich immer noch nicht verloren. Nach 21 Spieltagen, 19 Siege, zwei Unentschieden, 43 zu 12 Tore. Das liest sich ziemlich langweilig.
Ja, ist es von der Tabellenkonzentration her auf jeden Fall. Glücklicherweise hat die Liga noch sehr viele anderen interessanten Aspekte und Kampf um die Plätze dahinter. Dass es so kommt, diese Saison, war fast zu erwarten wirklich, weil die Juve noch stärker ist und die direkten Konkurrenten leider schwächer in dieser Saison. Bei Paar hat man es erwarten können. Einige haben auch mich enttäuscht, gerade zu Saisonstart, die Roma zu schwach. Napoli hat es eigentlich lange sehr gut gemacht. Allerdings fehlt ihnen der wichtigste Mann auf der Trainerbank. Der hat auch gleich den zweitwichtigsten mit Schaschino mitgenommen, Chelsea. Es ging lange sehr gut. Allerdings hat Napoli in den letzten zwei Jahren Kader immer relativ dünn. Die ersten Sarris hatten immer zwölf oder 13 Spieler, die meistens gespielt haben. Das hat Ancelotti ein bisschen versucht aufzubrechen, ist aber in der Qualität, in der Breite her, einfach nicht zu vergleichen mit Juve. Selbst wenn es zwischendurch mal nicht läuft, das ist so floskelbehaftet, aber die gewinnen dann auch die Spiele 1-0, die werden dann die Zyniker genannt. Und wenn dann Kilini noch einen reinköpft, das ist frustrierend für alle anderen, die Fans der Alten Dame, liest sich das wirklich hervorragend. Da muss man keine Spannung mehr im Titelkampf herbeireden.
Nein, 11 Punkte Vorsprung, das ist dann schon relativ deutlich. Wie hat sich Cristiano Ronaldo eingefunden?
Er hat alles, was er gesagt hat, wahrgemacht, dass er da hingekommen ist, um ein neues Kapitel zu schreiben, um selber seinen Namen in die Geschichtsbücher einzutragen, was ihm ja immer sehr wichtig ist. Was aber für eine sportliche Mannschaft perfekt ist, weil er so geil drauf ist, Tore zu machen, Erfolge zu haben, hat so glaube ich eineinhalb Spiele gebraucht, um richtig da zu sein und jetzt zerschießt er dort auch alles.
Ich habe jetzt nicht so viele Spiele von Juve gesehen in dieser Saison. Wird er denn auch so eingebunden wie bei Real? Dass er sich zwischen die Innenverteidiger schiebt, wenn die Flanke kommt, dass dann auch vermehrt auf ihn geflankt wird und dass er in die 1 gegen 1-2-Elle auf den Flügeln geschickt wird und dann nach innen zieht, wie ist er eingebunden?
Er hat viele Freiheiten, nimmt sich die auch. Vielleicht nicht ganz so sehr wie bei Real, weil Alegri schon ein Trainer ist, der das Gefüge sehr wichtig ist. Dennoch sticht ein Spieler wie er immer hervor. Das Einzige, was er... So sagen wir, der kurze Pfosten bei Flanken gehört oft mal an Cukic. Der hat auch gestern im Pokal gefehlt, als sie gegen Atalanta rausgeflogen sind. Das hat man wirklich sehr, sehr stark gemerkt. Was dann so lustig ist, der war auch in der letzten Saison bei Cukic einer der wichtigsten bei Juve. Der hat sich von Alegri zum Flügestürmer umschulen lassen. Eigentlich meistens auf links gespielt. Viele Vorlagen, sehr mannschaftsdienlich, aber trotzdem auch mit extrem vielen Torabschlüssen. Du hast in der Bundesliga oft genug Spiele gesehen, das ist sehr unangenehm zu verteidigen. Einfach teilweise noch unangenehmer als CR7. Und wenn du dann zwei solche Spieler in der vordersten Front hast, dann wird es schon sehr schwierig für die.
Aber trotzdem jetzt das Ausscheigen gegen Atalanta. 0 zu 3 in der Coppa Italia, damit das Triple nicht mehr möglich. Was war da los?
Also zum einen haben sie sich alle drei Tore selber reingeschossen bzw. Atalanta aufgelegt. Allegri selbst hat gesagt, das lag so ein bisschen in der Luft. Das ist eine krasse Sensation auf jeden Fall. Allerdings ist es jetzt kein Zweitligist. Also Atalanta hat wirklich auch über die letzten drei, vier Jahre auch international schon gezeigt, dass sie wirklich gut Fußball spielen können, kommen übers Mannschaftsgefüge, haben einen sehr guten Trainer mit Gasper Rini, der da viel mit jungen Spielern auch arbeitet, die sehr taktisch diszipliniert stehen, viel Durchschlagskraft nach vorne haben. Und dann hat sich Gelini verletzt gestern noch und viele Abwehrfehler. Vorne hat man Cukic gefehlt und das war dann wirklich so die 20 Minuten, bevor dann das 3-0 gefallen ist, als man gedacht hat, wenn sie jetzt eins machen, dann ist es halt dann vielleicht das 2-2 und gewinnt es in der Verlängerung oder im Elfmeterschießen, aber es war sehr ideenlos, kaum ein Abschluss. Haben sich dann auch noch mit dem Schiedsrichter viel beschäftigt. Mr. Allegri selbst auch, ist auch der Bank verwiesen worden, hat danach aber den Schiedsrichter auch dafür gelobt und hat gemeint, es war absolut richtig. Also in dem Sinne ein Ehrenmann. Also das ist ein ganz großer Trainer, der ganz viel Respekt bekommt. Wahrscheinlich so viel Respekt, den sich Thomas Doll wünschen würde. Der wird auf jeden Fall noch mit Mr. angesprochen.
Jetzt jaulen die Hannover 96-Fans auf, dass wir es sogar geschafft haben, hier in einem Kurzpass über die Serie A noch Hannover 96 unterzubringen. Atalanta, du sagst, es sind ja aktuell Tabellen siebter. Ich erinnere mich auch daran, dass die immer auch zu Hause sehr unangenehm zu bespielen waren. Haben wir ja auch gesehen, in den Duellen mit Dortmund haben auch die meisten Tore aus dem laufenden Spiel heraus erzielt. Serie A weit, also auch noch mehr als Juve beispielsweise. 32 Tore aus dem laufenden Spiel heraus, das ist schon ein sehr, sehr ordentlicher Wert nach 21 Ligaspielen. Also eben keine Laufkundschaft. Und dann kann halt so ein Aussetzer mal passieren und dann ist Juve draußen.
Ja, es ist jetzt natürlich auch, glaube ich, vier Dubels in Folge. Wird es dieses Jahr nicht geben. Jetzt könnten sie wenn dann noch das Double mit Champions League und Meisterschaft eintüten, was sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht ablehnen würden. Wobei gestern also bei Twitter auch Juve-Fans, da ist es schon wieder Weltuntergangsszenarien heraufgespuren.
Ja, das kennen die halt nicht mehr. Das sieht man ja bei den Bayern auch mal. Wenn die mal verlieren, dann geht auch das Abendland unter.
Und sind für mich persönlich trotzdem noch Top-Favorit oft die Champions League, wenn man so was haben kann, bei so vielen guten Mannschaften. Aber die haben halt wirklich mit Ronaldo noch das letzte Quäntchen dazu. Und irgendwie sehe ich es kommen, dass sie das Finale gegen Buffon und PSG gewinnen.
Ja, mal gucken. Die Neymar-Verletzung, der hat ja noch mal ein paar Konstanten ein bisschen verschoben, fand ich, in der Champions League. Und vor allem Barca und City, die sind dieses Jahr noch mal auf einem anderen Level. Und bei Liverpool, ja gut, da kann man sich nicht so ganz sicher sein. Auf jeden Fall wird es knallen gegen Atletico jetzt. Das ist ein sehr, sehr interessantes Spiel in der Champions League. Und da wird es dann um mehr gehen für Juve. Aber hier in der Serie A kann man da relativ schnell drüber gehen, kann sagen, okay, also es gab keinen Einbruch, eher bei den Verfolgern. Und du hast ja Napoli auch schon kurz angesprochen. Lass da noch mal ein bisschen tiefer reingehen. Sari weg, Xorginho weg, dafür Carlo Ancelotti da. Sie liegen auf Tabellenplatz zwei, aber eben mit diesen 11 Punkten Rückstand, aber auch acht Punkten Vorsprung. Das ist doch in Summe, auch wenn es natürlich ein bisschen einen ärgert, dass man Juve nicht angreifen kann, aber ist das doch ein Top-Ergebnis für Napoli? So jetzt Stand, jetzt.
Ja, kann man absolut so sagen. Also ich war selbst auch ein bisschen überrascht davon, wie gut Ancelotti das da gemacht hat, weil er das sehr clever gemacht hat. Das hat ganz viele Spielelemente beibehalten, die man auch schon unter Sarris gesehen hat. Also ganz viele Tore gleichen eigentlich den Angriffen der letzten Saison, hat aber zum Beispiel Lorenzo Insigne viel, viel gefährlicher wieder gemacht. Der hat letzte Saison ein bisschen unterperformed, was so die Tore anging, was glaube ich auch dann in letzter Instanz die Meisterschaft gekostet hat, wo man sie wirklich zum Greifen nahe hatte. Hat ihm da ein bisschen mehr Freiheiten gegeben, er kommt jetzt auch mal öfter im Zentrum, darf selber mehr abschließen, hat eine überragende Schusstechnik, sehr ballwendig, also einer, mit dem man sehr viel anstellen kann und halt ein SSC-Herz sowieso, eine Mannschaft, die viel natürlich auch über Fans und Leidenschaft kommt, haben auch, glaube ich, deswegen ganz lange den Kader zusammen behalten können, weil sich viele Spieler darüber im Klaren waren, dass wenn du eine Meisterschaft mit Napoli holst, dann ist es mehr wert als zehn mit Juve oder einem anderen Verein, weil da halt wirklich die ganze Region so auf den SSC abfährt. Also Napoli hat mich nicht wirklich enttäuscht dieses Jahr, wie du schon sagst, also acht Punkte vor Inter. Klar, die elf hinter Juve tun weh, waren aber wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie klar, wenn man gerade dieses, also wenn du so ein Spielsystem wie unter Sarris hast, das über Jahre gewachsen ist, wo die Spieler sich wirklich, man kann sich da so Thronen-Trainings-Videos bei YouTube angucken von ihm noch, wie die alle wirklich an der Schnur aufgezogen, die Abwehrspieler zwei Stunden lang nur trainieren, wie sie hoch und runter gehen, wenn ein langer Ball kommt. Und dann hast du eben diesen Xochinho im Mittelfeld, der eigentlich alles an sich gerissen hat, noch immer mehr dadurch, dass Hamcik auch immer älter geworden ist. Und war letzte Saison, glaube ich, auch schon meist ausgewechselter Spieler der Serie A. Bei dem hat es immer bis zur 65., 70. Jahre gereicht. Da weiß ich auch nicht, ob es am Alter lag oder ob er so oft um Sari rumstand und so viel mit Passiv geraucht hat. Ich weiß es nicht. Der ja auch gerne auf dem Trainingsplatz selber sich noch die Kippen angezündet hat. Wenn das dann wegbricht, wird es sehr schwierig. Die hatten schon davor auch immer relativ talentierte Spieler auf den Positionen. Auch ein Rock, der ist weggegangen, ist den ich sehr stark empfinde, der aber halt unter Sari. Und das waren auch oft Streitpunkte mit dem Präsidenten, eigentlich zu wenig zum Zug gekommen ist, weil Sari meistens wirklich halt so, der hatte seine 13, 14 Spieler und dann hat es aufgehört. Und jetzt hast du im Mittelfeld Cilinski und Alain, die da so ein bisschen versuchen zu managen. Aber hat man jetzt auch im Pokalspiel gegen Milan gesehen, als sie dort San Siro 2-0 verloren haben, dass es da dann doch in den, so beim allerletzten Quäntchen fehlen ein, zwei Mal die genialen Momente, die man unter Sari noch hatte. Was man, glaube ich, aber auch nicht unbedingt vorwerfen kann. Also dass die jetzt noch mal so eine Saison spielen, wie letztes Jahr und bis drei Spieltage vor Schluss dran sind.
Das war die Ausnahme der letzten Saison. Aber du hast es ja schon angesprochen. Jetzt gegen Milan im Pokal ausgeschieden, in der schwierigen Gruppe mit PSG und Liverpool dritter geworden. Deswegen jetzt dann in der Europa League gegen den FC Zürich. Sind die Napolitaner genauso entspannt wie du?
Gute Frage. Also ich glaube, entspannt sind die Napolitaner nie, wenn sie Fußball gucken und wenn es um Fußball geht. Ich glaube dieses Jahr aber allerdings, dass da die Chance einen Titel zu holen größer ist als unter Sarris, der letztes Jahr auch wirklich gegen Leipzig abgeschenkt hat. Auch wenn das viele mit deutschen Brille nicht so wahr haben wollten.
Hat sich ja Leipzig auch daran orientiert.
Ja, das hat man deutlich gesehen, dass da alles auf die Meisterschaft gesetzt wurde. Selbst im Pokal wurde da, ich glaube gegen Atalanta sogar, ziemlich fahrlässig mit umgegangen. Und jetzt nachdem der Pokal weg ist, glaube ich, dass Angelotti so ein Trainer ist, der auch sagt, wir holen jetzt einfach einen Titel wieder nach Napoli. Das hat mir sehr wehgetan, dass sie in der Champions League rausgegangen sind. Die zwei deutschen Trainer sind weitergekommen, die meisten anderen in der Redaktion waren zufrieden. Aber mir als großer, also war unter Sari und jetzt auch immer noch, großer Fan der Spieler und der Spielanlage, wie Napoli Fußball spielt. Und das hat mir schon sehr wehgetan, als sie in der Gruppe rausgegangen sind. Das war das schon auch, als ich die Gruppenlauslosung gesehen habe, weil ich gewusst habe, dass sie eine Mannschaft haben, die auf jeden Fall ins Achtelfinale kommen können und in der Gruppe, ja.
Das war hart, ja. Und vor allem noch nach dieser taktischen Meisterleistung zu Hause gegen Liverpool. Das war eins. Also das war für mich, da hat sich mein komplettes Anji-Lotti-Bild wieder auf Prä-Bayern gedreht. Also ab jetzt ist er für mich wieder einfach der, den man dachte, dass er zu Bayern kommen würde. Hier war irgendwie alles komisch, alles war merkwürdig. Man hat sich gedacht, wirklich bist du's? Oder hast du irgendwie deinen Zwillingsbruder geschickt? Oder was ist denn da los? Und in diesem Spiel, wie er da Jürgen Klopp ausgecoacht hat, vom Allerfeinsten mit einem...
Ich glaube, Liverpool keinen Schuss aufs Tor gehabt in dem Spiel.
Ja, es war eine so starke Partie. Und dann dennoch rauszugehen, klar ist nur eins von mehreren Spielen in der Champions League und ist schwierig, aber ja. Aber das könnte tatsächlich sein, wenn es in der Liga, ja, sieht es recht entspannt aus. Vielleicht muss ich da jetzt der FC Zürich in der Zwischenrunde der Europa League warm anziehen.
Stimmt, da gibt es ja sowas wie Zwischenrunde.
Ja, ich musste auch gerade mal näher rangehen, um es nachzulesen. Weil ich wusste, es ist nicht Achtelfinale. Ja, ach, es ist auch einfach ein schöner Wettbewerb. Ich freue mich, wenn da jetzt die Europa League zwei kommt. Ja, die Konferenz dazu ist ja tatsächlich super. Wie nennt ihr die nochmal? Die Go Zone. Genau, die mag ich sehr gerne. Das ist eine Art und Weise, Europa League zu gucken. Da gucke ich auch, obwohl ich ja eigentlich diesen Wettbewerb normalerweise weglasse, um den Donnerstag frei zu machen. Aber das steht auf einem anderen Blatt. Lass uns über die beiden Mailander Clubs sprechen und die Tabelle. Schreibt es uns vor, dass wir damit Inter anfangen. Die liegen mit 40.8 Punkte hinter Neapel, 19 Punkte hinter Juve, aber auch fünf vor dem großen Rivalen, vor dem AC Milan. Wie ist die Situation bei Inter?
Ganz gut, würde ich sagen. Also das ist auch da, wo sie hingehören, mit Kader und mit dem, was sie abrufen. Spalletti hat immer mal wieder seine Probleme gehabt zwischendurch. Jetzt haben sie es wieder gefunden, haben sich ganz ordentlich verstärkt. Also auch der hat jetzt zuletzt war auch wieder verletzungsanfällig, aber in Neingolan war ein ziemlich guter Transfer, fand ich. Auch Blauturo Martinez hat sich ganz gut eingefügt. Dann haben sie natürlich Icardi, der gefühlt nie über 15 Ballkontakte kommt, aber trotzdem drei Tore gemacht. Das ist auch ein Phänomen. Und wenn er dann am Strafraum den Ball bekommt, dann weißt du halt auch, warum er, also klasse Fußballer einfach. Aber auch für mich eigentlich klar gewesen, dass die nicht zu den Teams gehören, die noch mehr Punkte von Juve wegnehmen können oder das noch spannender gestalten können. Am letzten Spieltag haben wir am letzten Saison erst noch die Champions League-Quali klargemacht mit so einem verrückten Spiel bei Lazio. Und die sind jetzt da auf Platz drei mit sechs vor dem fünften Platz. Da sind sie eigentlich ziemlich genau da, wo ich sie erwartet habe. Die spielen nicht immer den attraktivsten Fußball. Am letzten Saison waren sie auch mal in der Vorrunde kurz erster. Und dann kam so eine Phase November, Dezember, da haben dann einfach zwei, drei Spieler, unter anderem auch Perisic nicht funktioniert, der immer noch so ein kleines Tief hat. Deswegen geht es nicht weiter nach oben. Aber da auch wieder der Punkt, dass du halt, dann weißt du, dass es auch nicht weiter nach oben gehen kann, wenn du halt auf diesen einen Spieler auf der Position so sehr angewiesen bist, dass es dann, wenn er nicht funktioniert, dann spielst du auf einmal irgendein deppertes Unentschieden, das es nicht braucht, gegen den Mittelfeldkandidaten, was dann auch wieder den Unterschied ausmacht im Vergleich zu einer Mannschaft wie Juve.
Und hatten auch ein bisschen Pech mit ihrer Champions League Gruppe zusammen mit Barca, Tottenham und dem PSV Eindhoven auch in der Europa League gelandet.
Wobei, da haben sie am letzten Spieltag selber das Ding aus der Hand gegeben, glaube ich, mit dem 1-1 gegen Eindhoven.
Genau, sie hätten da gewinnen müssen und haben doch da relativ spät den Ausgleich passiert.
Und das war dann halt wieder so ein Spiel, ich glaube, da wurde auch viel über das Ballett, die geschimpft. Ich meine sogar, dass da hat zeitgleich Barca-Tottenham gespielt und Barca führte und ich habe zwischenzeitlich bei Inter dann das Gefühl gehabt, dass sie sich darauf verlassen haben, dass Tottenham in Barcelona nicht wieder zurückkommt und dann so 20 Minuten Verwalterfußball gespielt haben, wo ich mir gedacht habe, also wenn du mit einem Sieg zuhause gegen Eindhoven, die weiß Gott kein schlechtes Team sind, aber als Inter-Mailand, du kannst mit einem Heimsieg das Achtelfinale klar machen, dann spiele ich da auf einen Sieg und da haben sie halt Angst gehabt, das Zweite zu kassieren von Eindhoven irgendwie. Ich glaube, einem Punkt hätte ihnen gereicht, wenn Tottenham bei Barca verloren hätte. Und das ist dann...
Genau, es war andersrum. Sie lagen 0-1 hinten durch PSV, sind dann in der 73. zurückgekommen zum 1-1 und hätten dann aber aus 2-1 gehen müssen. Und Tottenham hat nämlich, das habe ich jetzt zweierwegs, Tottenham hat fünf Minuten vor Schluss das 1-1 gemacht. Und damit war dann Inter...
Genau, und dann haben sie auf einmal, und das verstehe ich dann auch nicht mal, die letzten sechs Minuten hat Inter dann wieder Vollgas gespielt, also als hätten die das wirklich gesagt bekommen. Und das verstehe ich halt nicht.
Ja, da haben sie versucht, die Tabelle zu spielen und die Tabelle hat ihnen aber einen Streich gespielt. Immerhin steht man ja in der Serie A mit Tabellenplatz 3 wunderbar da. Und das Wichtigste ist ja sowieso für jeden Inter-Fan, nachdem man sich von dem Meister schafft, der sowieso jetzt schon seit Längerem eigentlich verabschieden musste. Das Wichtigste ist ja, dass man vor Milan steht. Und die kommen jetzt dahinter und haben einen wichtigen Transfer gemacht im Winter.
Ja, der Kollege Piontek, der von Genoa kam, direkt auch erstes Spiel, zwei Tore im Pokal gegen Napoli. Das ist schon eine richtige Maschine im Sturm vorne. Ich glaube, den wird man noch bei der ein oder anderen größeren WM-Runde in der Champions League oder so qualifizieren, wird der von auf sich aufmerksam machen. Allerdings steht Milan sogar ein bisschen besser da, als ich sie erwartet hätte. Was aber vielleicht eher daran liegt, dass die anderen schwächer sind. Ich hoffe, jetzt hören die ganzen Milan-Fans nicht zu, die mir letztens das Fell über die Ohren gezogen haben, als ich die mal live kommentiert habe in der Coppa-Achtelfinale. Da habe ich 45 Minuten von denen gesehen und das war sehr ernüchternd.
Weil? Wegen der Art des Fußballs?
Ja, sie hatten da auch eine Phase, da hatten sie dann auch Higuaiden-Sechsspiele nicht getroffen oder sieben. Da hatten sie ganz viele Unentschieden in Folge, vier Spiele in Folge, keinen eigenen Treffer. Und standen dann trotzdem nur zwei Punkte hinter dem Champions League-Platz. Sie haben dann 2-1 mal gegen Spall Ferrara gewonnen, als Higuaiden dann endlich wieder getroffen hatte. Aber davor war es wirklich Krütze. Und jetzt bei Sampdoria, als sie dann noch in der Verlängerung gewonnen haben, das war von beiden Teams sehr, sehr schlecht. Aber bei Milan muss man sagen, die haben oft Probleme, ins Tempo zu kommen. Wenn der Gegner tief steht, hat man dann auch ab und an das Gefühl, dass die Spieler keine richtige Idee haben, was man dann auch wieder auf den Trainer Gattuso ummünzen müsste. Also, dass halt nur gesichert stehen, Ballbesitz langsam nach vorne, dann drauf hoffen, dass einer von diesen guten Kickern mit einem starken Schuss Shalanolu, Suso oder damals noch Higuain einen rein macht. Aber so die Strecke dazwischen war wirklich ganz viele Halbfeld-Flanken von Suso und Shalanolu. Shalanolu ist glaube ich eh kein Tempospieler. Das in einer Phase, in der die Mannschaft dann auch wenig Selbstvertrauen bzw. wenig taktische Ideen oder Möglichkeiten hat, war sehr schwierig anzuschauen, muss ich sagen. Deswegen stehen die mit einem 4. Tabellenplatz. Also Champions League Qualifikation wäre für Milan dieses Jahr ein absoluter Erfolg, auch wenn Leonardo, der Sportdirektor, sagt, das ist überlebenswichtig hinsichtlich Bilanzen und Einnahmen und da hat ja auch der eine oder andere italienische Verein noch das eine oder andere Sparbuch auszugleichen.
Man hörte davon, ja.
Und aus meiner Sicht ein Erfolg. Sie müssen, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall, Gattuso muss auch Champions League schaffen, damit er eine Berechtigung hat, dort zu bleiben. Weil es ist halt natürlich trotzdem Milan. Da ist auch ganz schnell ein anderer Trainer wieder da, oder?
Es ist ja auch gerade möglich. Also man erkennt auch, warum sie mit Piontek, den ich früher immer Piatek ausgesprochen habe, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, bevor Majo mir das beigebracht hat, also wundert euch nicht über den Wurde auch im letzten Kurspass, da haben wir nämlich noch darüber gesprochen, dass er so mit einer der heißesten Stürmer Europas gerade war und die Frage so war, wohin geht er. Es gibt einen Grund, warum man ihn geholt hat. Du hast es schon beschrieben, dass offensiv ein bisschen einfallslos und auch nicht wirklich durchlagskräftig mit 28 Treffern nach 21 Spielen hat man bei weitem den schlechtesten Sturm von den ersten neun Teams der Serie A, die alle anderen haben häufiger getroffen. Da gibt es noch Nachholbedarf bei Milan, aber aktuell ist es ja der Champions League-Platz und deswegen muss das ja irgendwie dann auch das Ziel sein.
Aber auch da im Pokal, da hat man das gleich gesehen, das war zwar, ich glaube das erste Tor war so ein Ball von der Mittellinie, der ganz knapp über dem Scheitel des Abwehrspielers vorbeirauscht, er antizipiert das richtig, verarbeitet den mit einem Kontakt, zieht nach innen und hat dann ohne den Kopf hochzunehmen, schweißt den irgendwie am langen Pfosten rein. Er weiß, wo das Tor steht. Er kann sogar noch mit dem Ball umgehen. Schnell, körperlich stark, sehr jung. Er hat jetzt auch viele gute Spieler um sich herum, die durchaus auch Pässe spielen können, wenn sie in einer guten Phase sind. Dann kann sich das natürlich auch ein bisschen verselbstständigen auf jeden Fall.
Ja, also da können wir gespannt sein.
Ja, das ist krass, das ist mir selber noch gar nicht so aufgefallen, wenn das jetzt so 28 Tore nur, der Rest, Inter fällt noch ab, aber ansonsten, Atalanta auf 747.
Ja, da wollte ich mit dir noch drüber sprechen. Das ist mir nämlich jetzt gerade, als ich diese Moderation gemacht habe, ist mir das nämlich auch aufgefallen, dass Atalanta in 21 Spielen 77 Torbeteiligung herausgespielt hat. Also da war immer was los, dann lass doch an der Stelle auch tatsächlich über Atalanta sprechen. Also wir haben ja vorhin schon thematisiert, das 3-0 gegen Juve jetzt in der Coppa Italia. Natürlich ein großer Erfolg. Wir erinnern uns auch an das Duell mit Borussia Dortmund im letzten Jahr. Spätestens da hat man es als deutscher Fußballfan auch so ein bisschen mitbekommen, was da so im Bergamo passiert. Jetzt schnuppert man so ein bisschen an den Europa League Plätzen. Rein theoretisch ist auch der Abstand zur Champions League aktuell mit drei Punkten nicht weit. Das ist alles sehr, sehr eng. Und in dem Teil der Tabelle ist es am spannendsten in der Serie A. Wie würdest du denn die Lage bei Atalanta bewerten?
Ich glaube, Champions League wäre zu viel für die, weil wirklich immer auch Kader mit sehr vielen jungen Spielern, die kommen da auch übers Kollektiv, kommen über einen Trainer mit Gasperini, der sie wirklich sehr gut einstellt, der eine gute Spielidee hat, sowohl nach vorne als auch nach hinten. Also das hat man gestern auch gesehen, auch wenn sie jetzt da nicht die Top-Defensive in der Liga sind, Juve bei Null zu halten.
Ja, das ist natürlich was.
Und zwar auch wirklich, ohne so richtig ins Zittern gekommen zu sein, haben mit Alejandro Papu Gomes einen Kapitän, der die alle führt, der selber richtig gut kicken kann, am Tor gefährlich ist, von Zapata, den ich auch schon seit zwei, drei Jahren eigentlich richtig, richtig gut finde. Der hätte vielleicht auch schon ein Jahr vorher so richtig den Durchbruch schaffen können.
Er hat 20 Tore in 29 Pflichtenspielen für Atalanto gemacht.
Also bei ihm läuft es halt richtig. Und er ist auch ein geiler Typ, einfach so bullig, schnell, kann Gewaltschüsse, kann auch überlegt einschieben. Und dahinter eben viele jungen ambitionierten Spieler. Ich glaube, ein Deutscher hüpft auch rum. Robin Gossens, der gelernter Linksverteidiger, aber in dem System von Gasparini auch einer sein kann, der von Eckfahne zu Eckfahne unterwegs ist und auch im Mittelfeld spielen kann, wenn man mal hinten umstellt. Nur auf Dreierkette, wo er dann so halb mit zum Mittelfeld dazugehört. Auch ein Pajalić im Mittelfeld. Sehr interessant, bzw. so hängende Spitze eher. Ich glaube, Ilićic hat gestern gar nicht gespielt. Das ist auch wieder einer von den älteren Erfahrenen, der aber auch ordentlich kicken kann. Wir haben ja jetzt auch viele italienischen Kollegen bei uns durch das Zone Italia. Und Gasperini war immer, da haben sich ganz viele gewünscht, dass er der neue Nationaltrainer wird. Weil er eben auch durch diesen Umgang mit jungen Spielern so einen Umbruch hätte einleiten können. Was dagegen spricht, ist, dass dann die anderen wieder sagen, dass es einer ist, der jeden Tag mit der Mannschaft arbeiten muss. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was auch bei Atalanta ein großes Plus ist. Dass es eine Mannschaft, die auch für italienische Verhältnisse sehr lange an ihm schon festhält, der hat da jetzt, glaube ich, vom Präsidenten das Angebot bekommen, von mir aus bis zur Rente, kann das Vertrag unterschreiben.
Da kann natürlich nichts schiefgehen.
Er kann selber hinten die Zahl dranhängen. Ich glaube, hat er selber aber großzügig abgelehnt.
Und könnt ihr der tatsächlich für die deutsche Nationalmannschaft noch spielen? Also er hat in der Junioren, hat, glaube ich, mal im Juniorenteam der Niederlande gespielt, aber ich finde das interessant, dass, also, Entschuldigung, ich bin gerade gesprungen von Gasperine zu Robin Grosens wieder zurück. Wir zwei haben es gesehen, weil ich hier einen neuen Tap aufgemacht habe, aber die Hörerinnen und Hörer sind jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen überrascht. Ich bin ein bisschen hellhörig geworden, weil ich das interessant fand, dass du auf einmal hier einen Deutschen mit niederländischen Wurzeln auch ins Spiel bringst, den ich so nicht mehr auf dem Schirm hatte. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das rund um das BVB-Spiel, wahrscheinlich habe ich es da mal gehört und gleich wieder vergessen.
Es wird schon eine Matze gegeben haben, der deutschen Niederländer beim Dortmunder Gegner.
Das wird bestimmt auch sehr lustig und informativ gewesen sein, aber ich gucke auch nicht so viel Vorberichte, ehrlich gesagt. Aber das ist ja interessant, ein 24-jähriger Deutscher, geboren in Emmerich, der bei Atalanta Bergamo, die mehr Tore erzielt haben als Juve, linke Verteidiger spielt. Das ist ja auch eine von den Positionen, wo man sagt, schwierig Leute zu finden. Ich will ihn jetzt nicht in die Nationalmannschaft sprechen. Nein, nein, nein.
Also wahrscheinlich sowieso, ich hoffe, er strafft mich dann nicht lügen, aber wahrscheinlich unter Jogi Löw eher nicht. Prinzipiell ist da, glaube ich, auch so ein Ding, wie groß ist die Serie A-Lobby in Deutschland? Das merke ich auch oft in Gesprächen mit Kollegen, schon ab und zu immer noch unter dem Radar, weil die vier, fünf Jahre davor richtig schlecht waren. War bei mir selber auch so, dass es ein bisschen verschwunden ist, als Kind der 90er.
Man hat es auch eine ganze Weile nicht gern geguckt, weil wenn man ehrlich ist, waren auch die Spiele wirklich nicht gut.
Ja, und dann kommt noch dazu, dass halt wirklich zum Teil die Stadien sehr leer waren. Das wird wieder sehr viel besser, auch gerade Atalanta ist immer super Atmosphäre. Gestern, als ich Florenz kommentiert habe, war es auch so, wir haben dieses Jahr auch wieder einen Zuschausschnitt von über 30.000. Das macht schon wieder Spaß, aber ich glaube wirklich, dass dadurch, dass die Liga so ein paar Jahre komplett weg vom Schirm war, waren auch in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren viele Journalisten-Kollegen immer sehr überrascht, wenn da auf einmal wieder eine italienische Mannschaft Fußball gespielt hat. Was wiederum manchmal ein bisschen, was dann schade ist, dadurch, dass ich bei der Zone auch für die Liga verantwortlich bin und dann gibt es mal wieder ein Topspiel und das ist aber mal wirklich so. Also Katinaccio gibt es nicht mehr so, wie er glorifiziert wird oder beschrieben wird, auch von deutschen Kollegen aus. Nicht außer, wenn es dann solche Topspiele sind. Und da habe ich dann ganz oft Moderatoren oder Leiter der Sendung und dann freuen sie sich wirklich auf ein Topspiel. Aber wenn Juve Napoli spielt oder Juve Inter, dann kannst du schon auch Geld draufsetzen, dass es 1-0 oder 0-0 wird. Weil dann machen die Vereine in der Liga das wirklich schon viel deutlicher so als in anderen Ligen, dass sich sehr, sehr krass nach dem Gegner gerichtet wird. Dass es wirklich darum geht, mit einem Punkt rauszugehen aus dem Spiel, im besten Fall. Oder nicht im besten Fall, aber dass man auf jeden Fall den Kauf nimmt.
Dass man erst einmal den Punkt sichert und dann der Bonus sind quasi die extra zwei Punkte, die man draufsetzt. So ein bisschen wie Italien ja auch eigentlich jedes größere Turnier angeht. Ich glaube, daher kommt ja auch dieses Vorurteil, was ja dann in diesen Teilen eben stimmt. Aber das ist mir eben jetzt auch aufgefallen, seitdem ich mich, ich würde sagen, seit der letzten Saison durch die Einführung auch der internationalen Kurzpässe, gucke ich ja häufiger auch in die internationalen Liga, ohne dass ich Zeit hätte, Spiele zu gucken. Aber da sehe ich eben allein an den Ergebnissen, dass du halt 514142, da ist alles mit dabei. Und auch wenn jetzt gerade die Bundesliga sich rühmen kann, die throrreichste Liga Europas zu sein, ist es nicht so viel schlechter in der Serie A. Ich wusste, dass du jetzt genau mit diesem Takt nämlich rüberkommen kannst. Und Atalanta mit eben 47 erzielten Toren, das ist schon wirklich...
Also wirklich, da muss man mal sagen, dann freut euch nicht einmal im Monat Juve-Inter, sondern schaut euch lieber mal zwischendurch Florenz-Atalanta an. Oder die Roma dieses Jahr vielleicht nicht. Aber auch Sampdoria mit Cuairella, der Fabio letztes Jahr seine beste Saison gespielt hat und die dieses Jahr noch toppen wird. Der hat jetzt in elf Spielen, in denen er eingesetzt wurde, in Folge getroffen. Wenn er am Wochenende trifft, ist er alleiniger Rekordhalter. Fabio Cuairella.
Verrückt. Gegen wen spielt Genua? Weiß es gerade aus, wenn ich Sampdoria? Ansonsten kann ich es uns auch gleich sagen. Du erzählst mir bis dahin, wie die auf den Tabellenplatz 6 gekommen sind. Die sind ja auch mitten in der Verlosung drin für Europa League und vielleicht auch Champions League Plätze.
Sehr guter Trainer auch mit Gianpaolo. Das ist eher noch einer von der alten Schule defensiv sehr stark eingestelltes Team. Vorne Quarella, der dieses Jahr alles trifft. Deswegen brauchen sie auch Wawnazki nicht mehr. Ich war heute gar nicht am Deadline, der ist so richtig, aber ich glaube, der ist jetzt wirklich zu Düsseldorf.
Der ist zu Düsseldorf, genau.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Den habe ich zwei, drei Mal gesehen. Hat schon die Anlagen, aber ein bisschen Tendenz, Chancen, Tod. Oder kommt halt dieses Jahr auch zu selten zum Zug. Ich warte immer darauf, dass Cassano noch mal um die Ecke gerannt kommt. Die haben auch zwei, drei richtig gute Spieler im Mittelfeld. Ein Linetti, weiß gar nicht, was das für ein Landsmann ist. Ein Belgier, Dennis Pratt. Und Samdoria gucke ich auch wirklich gerne beim Kicken zu.
Das hört sich tatsächlich ganz interessant an. Linetti ist ein Pole. Das nächste Spiel wird gegen Napoli sein. Nicht die einfachste Aufgabe, aber wenn man sich ein Rekord holt, dann mit dem Tor gegen Napoli, würde ich sagen. Wirkt das jetzt gerade nur so oder ist die Renaissance des Stürmers voll angekommen in der Serie A? Weil in der letzten Saison schon ein bisschen so.
Ja, nee doch. Ich glaube es wirklich nur so. Bei allen diesen Top-Clubs hast du immer einen bärenstarken drin. Also Juve müssen wir nicht drüber reden. Napoli, Mertens, Inter, Icardi, Milan jetzt mit Biontech, Roma mit Cecho, wobei ich nicht weiß, ob er noch so viel spielen wird nach seiner Aktion gestern.
Lass uns dann gleich zu den Römer-Clubs einfach drüber wechseln.
Was war da? Irdin Cecho ist zur Halbzeit eingewechselt worden beim Stand von 3-1 für Florenz. Davor hat Schick im Sturmzentrum gespielt, das ja auch so ein gehyptes Sturmtalent ist, der mir aber gar nicht gefällt in dieser Saison. Der hat dann deutlich besser funktioniert, als er auf dem Außen war. Und dann hatte die Roma auch nochmal eine gute Phase. Er hätte fast das 3-2 gemacht, kassiert das dann das 4-1 und wegen einer Nichtigkeit, da ist Lorenzo Pellegrini gefault worden, vor dem Strafraum aber nach außen hin, hat es den Pfiff nicht bekommen, hat sich tierisch aufgeregt. Also was dann beim 4-1 natürlich bei Fußballprofis auch einsetzt, dann arbeitet man sich am Schiedsrichter ab und da fährt davor in der Partie gar nichts. Also es gab keine kniffligen Entscheidungen, es war kein überhartes Spiel, der Schiedsrichter stand nicht im Fokus, aber Pellegrini auch zur Halbzeit, das hat mit Cecho eingewechselt, hat sich tierisch aufgeführt, hat eine gelbe Karte wegen Meckerns bekommen und dann ist Edin Cecho zum Schiedsrichter hingegangen und hat ihm ein paar Takte gesagt und hat währenddessen, es gibt einige Boulevard-Zeitungen, die heute damit getitelt haben, dass er ihn angespuckt hätte. Also ich hab das Spiel kommentiert und mir das danach noch mehrmals angeschaut. Ich kann nicht erkennen, dass Flüssigkeit aus seinem Mund kommt, aber es ist eine Spuckgeste. Also er steht wirklich einen halben Meter vor einem Schiedsrichter und macht so, als würde er sozusagen vor ihm auf den Boden spucken, was natürlich trotzdem eine rote Karte ist. Ich fand das nur lustig, dass Edin Cecho spuckt Schiedsrichter an, verkauft sich besser als Edin Cecho tut so, als würde er den Schiedsrichter anspucken. Da darf ja jeder sein Geld verdienen, wie er möchte.
Aber quasi eine Undiszipliniertheit.
Eine Undiszipliniertheit und danach noch mehrere Worte gefallen. Der ist ja auch schon eine Weile in Rom. Der wird auch die italienischen Schimpfworte gut im Repertoire haben. Danach noch fast dem Kollegen Chiesa an die Gurgel gegangen. Und wenn man sich diese Sequenz ein paar Mal hintereinander anschaut, dann möchte man davon ausgehen, dass da vermutlich auch eine Sperre kommen wird, die sich auf die Liga auswirken wird bei so einem Vergehen. Ich habe so Sperren schätzen, das ist immer schwierig, aber ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass Cecho bis zu acht Spiele bekommt dafür. Weil es war wirklich grob unsportlich.
Okay, und könnte das jetzt auch tatsächlich schon im nächsten Spiel kommen gegen Milan? Das ist nämlich die nächste Partie für die Roma. Und das ist Tabellenplatz fünf mit 34 Punkten. Roma gegen Tabellenplatz vier mit 34 Punkten. Und Milan hat 35 Punkte. Also da geht es um die Eme Ziegwürst.
Und da geht es vor allem auch nach der Partie gestern schon fast, würde ich sagen, um den Trainer-Posten von Eusebio Di Francesco. Weil, ich meine, mit 4-1 mal rausfliegen, mit 5-1. Aber das war wirklich der Wahnsinn. Die letzten drei Minuten hat Florenz sogar so Gnade vor Recht ergehen lassen, hat den Ball nur noch hintenrum sich hin und her geschoben. Und dann in der 90. Minute nochmal einen weiten Schlag nach vorne, wo dann auch Giovanni Simeone nochmal durchspringt und das 7 zu 1 macht. Wo dann in der zweiten Zeitlupe zu sehen war, dass die, also in Unterzahl, beim Stand von 1-6, standen die zwei Innenverteidiger in der Kette drei Meter hinter der Mittellinie. Wo dann auch mein Experte gesagt hat, also gehe ich einfach zehn Meter weiter nach hinten, die schlagen den Ball nicht lang. Und Florenz hatte dann Bock und hat gesagt, gut, dann schießen wir euch noch einen Sieblis rein. Und das ist dann natürlich ein 7-1. Ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern, dass sich, vor allem das war nicht Erste gegen Zweite Liga, also so auseinandergeschraubt zu werden in einem Pokalfiertelfinale. Viele sagen, der Pokal hat nicht so einen großen Stellenwert, aber die Francesco, nachdem sie davor am Wochenende eine 3-0-Führung in Atalanta aus der Hand gegeben haben, nach 43 Minuten 3-0 geführt und dann noch nur Unentschieden gespielt, der war so sauer. Auf dem Weg nach Florenz ist der Kollege Manolas, der auch an drei, vier Gegentoren wieder nicht ganz unbeteiligt war, auf dem Weg zum Bahnhof von einem Fan darum gebeten worden, doch mal aufzuwecken. Der hat den Fan daraufhin gesagt, er soll die Fresse halten und noch so ein italienisches Wort, das ich nicht zitieren möchte. Auf jeden Fall hat der Fanrecht behalten. Anscheinend hat auch Kollege Manolas gestern wieder unter aller Sau gespielt, wie die zweite Halbzeit bei Atalanta. Und wenn du dann diese drei Halbzeiten aneinander reißt und dir sagst, als Team, dass im Champions League Achtelfinale steht, letztes Jahr richtig stark war. Klar, die haben auch wichtige Spiele abgegeben, auch mit Alisson.
Eben, das wollte ich gerade sagen. Also Alisson, Nainggolan, Strootmann abgegeben, das sind so die größten Namen. War ja auch schon fast damit ein bisschen zu rechnen, dass man zumindest diese tolle Saison aus dem Feuer nicht wiederholen würde.
Ja, das ist immer so ein bisschen das Problem der Roma, dass die, obwohl sie ein Top-Team sind, doch auch immer viel Verlust haben an ganz großen Spielern. Ja, aber dann ist es auch an einem Trainer und an einem Team, da irgendwie ein bisschen Sicherheit rein zu bekommen. Also die ersten drei Gegentore haben sie bekommen, weil sie eine Vorwärtsbewegung, Fehlpass im Mittelfeld, über drei Meter den Ball, Gegner den Fuß und dann langer Ball auf Kiesa durch Tor. Also denen sind die Bälle um die Ohren geflogen. Und dann halt auch so eine Einstellungs-Sache. Also wenn du dich da dann noch 7-1 abschießen lässt, das darf dir halt als Fußballprofi nicht passieren.
Ja klar, ich denke, das haben jetzt schon alle verstanden. Also dann wissen wir auch, wie wichtig jetzt diese Partie der Roma gegen Milan ist. Aber wollen wir dann an der Stelle vielleicht auch noch ein Wort über Florenz verlieren? Weil das ist natürlich schon eine interessante Nummer, dass man da im Pokal eben dieses denkwürdige 7 zu 1 hinlegt. In der Liga mit 30 Punkten auf Platz 9 ist noch alles möglich, weil es sind drei Punkte Rückstand auf Europa League. Und es muss ja jetzt gar nicht sein. Und wir haben ja bei der Fiorentina gibt es ja ganz ganz viele Themen, die ja auch neben dem Platz alle zum Teil auch passiert sind. Wie ist denn deren Saison so einzuschätzen?
Ja, einfach nicht konstant genug. Also die haben schon die Qualität. Na, der wird nicht zuhören. Ich halte Pioli nicht für den allerbesten Trainer. Der macht gerne so Sachen, dass wenn was funktioniert, er vor wichtigen Spielen auch gerne mal nochmal was umstellt. Wo viele ihm dann auch persönliche Eitelkeit, also italienische Journalisten sagen dann erst persönlich manchmal ein bisschen, er versucht nochmal was ganz besonderes. Gestern war das auch so, gestern hat es super funktioniert. Da hat Muriel den Neuzugang ins Sturmzentrum gestellt und dafür Simone draußen gelassen und Miralas auf links spielen lassen. Also gestern ist alles aufgegangen. Aber die haben viel zu oft so Spiele drin, wo du dir denkst, was ist das jetzt?
Sie hat diese unglaublich lange Unentschiedenserie. Ich gucke gerade, vom 30. September an, das war der letzte Sieg bis zum 16. Dezember. Und dazwischen nur Unentschieden gespielt und zweimal verloren.
Ja, auch das 1-1 gegen Fro Sinone, also sowas darf ja nicht passieren. Fro Sinone wird eigentlich von jedem weggeschossen und dann hast du so eine Mannschaft, wo du wirklich mal sagen musst, du hast dann einen Chieser, auch dahinter haben sie mit Veritou, einen sehr guten Spieler im Mittelfeld. Also ich sehe die jetzt nicht jede Woche, also die Highlights gucke ich mir an, aber nicht jedes Spiel über 90 Minuten. Und wenn ich mir dann mal eines dieser Spiele anschaue, wo es dann nicht funktioniert, da frage ich mich so, wo stimmt es nicht? Ohne, dass ich es ihm jetzt aufzeichnen könnte, was er falsch macht, aber wo ich mir dann auch wieder denke, okay, das ist dann auch eine Trainersache, wenn die Spieler da sind und die sind sie auf jeden Fall. Also und hast eben mit Käser einen wirklich außergewöhnlichen Spieler vorne.
Ja, den magst du.
Den mag ich wirklich sehr gerne. Der könnte auch mit einer der entscheidenden Faktoren sein, wenn die Nationalmannschaft mal wieder was reißen sollte.
Hat jetzt zehn Treffer gemacht in 23 Pflichtspielen, 21 Jahre jung. Eben auch Italiener, das werden sich jetzt alle schon kombiniert haben, aus deiner Anmerkung denke ich.
Und ohne internationales Geschäft und selbst mit internationalem Geschäft wahrscheinlich über die Saison hinaus nicht zu halten bei Florenz. Also Inter und Juve mit ganz großem Interesse. Und wenn Juve wirklich will, bekommen sie auch die Spieler.
Ja gut, das haben wir glaube ich im Juve-Teil dann irgendwie indirekt schon angerissen, dadurch, dass die halt einfach alles gewinnen und man eben bei denen einfach die Titel holen kann und sich dessen dann auch sicher sein kann. Lass uns noch ganz kurz über Lazio sprechen. Dann haben wir die auch noch kurz zumindest erwähnt. Die liegen aktuell auf der Wellenplatz acht. Das sind zwei Punkte, also ein Punkt sogar nur auf Europa League, drei Punkte auf die Champions League Ränge. Spielen aber, so wie ich mich erinnere, das letzte Mal, als über Lazio gesprochen wurde, war das auch Konstanz war da, glaube ich, eines der Worte, was da gefallen ist.
Zum einen Konstanz, zum anderen glaube ich, tut ihnen noch die verpasste Champions League Qualifikation der letzten Saison sehr weh. Also sie haben am letzten Spieltag zu Hause gegen Inter, also war direkt das Duell. Lazio hätte sogar einen Punkt gereicht. Sie lagen in Führung bis zur 75. und dann hat Inter das Spiel noch gedreht.
Da knabbern sie noch dran.
Ich glaube schon. Und so gut Immobile bei Lazio funktioniert, so leicht ausrechenbar ist dann doch auch manchmal ihr Spiel. Und dann haben sie mit Milinkovic Savic einen hoch talentierten Mittelfeldspieler, der dieses Jahr, ich mag die Formulierung nicht, aber weit unter seinen Möglichkeiten spielt. Also klar auch noch ein sehr junger Kerl, da wurde letztes Jahr auch immer nur drüber geredet, ich weiß nicht, ob der Präsident ihm dann Gefallen getan hat, dass er gesagt hat, das ist der erste Spieler von Lazio, der über 100 Millionen Euro wert sein wird.
Ja gut, wenn die Leistung dann nicht stimmt, dann hat ihn keiner damit getan, dann kommt das noch mit dazu.
Ja, also teilweise zu leicht ausrechenbar, und dann die fehlende Konstanz vielleicht auch eine, jetzt hau ich schon wieder auf den Träner rein, ich weiß nicht, ob Simone noch zu den letzten Esprit hat, Simone Inzaghi, da gerade in so Situationen, wo es dann halt mal nicht ganz so rund läuft, wie hier.
Den Eindruck hatte ich nämlich auch in den Europa League Spielen. Da konnte man ja Lazio beobachten, und gerade gegen Eintracht Frankfurt, das hat man natürlich am ehesten noch verfolgt. Und sowohl im Hinspiel, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, mit dem ersten Gegentreffer war so eine Art Widerstand gebrochen, und dann hatten die keine Lust mehr, weil es sehr anstrengend war. Also ich, natürlich haben Profis Lust, und sie wollten dieses Spiel nicht verlieren, so meine ich es nicht, aber sie waren quasi nicht bereit, mit diesen schwierigen Bedingungen in einem völlig aufgeheizten Stadion, da quasi mit Gegenwind und Berg auf jetzt noch den Hügel hochzufahren. Und beim Rückspiel, das ging dann um nichts mehr, muss man sagen. Die Tabellen-Kontest-Illusion war ja so, dass beide schon durch waren. Aber da war es auch so, dass, obwohl da Lazio ja, ich glaube, sogar geführt hat, haben sie es völlig hergeschenkt und waren sehr passiv. Da war überhaupt kein Spirit zu sehen, dass man jetzt dieses Spiel einfach gewinnen will, weil man jedes Spiel gewinnen will. Auch wenn da jetzt nur 2000 eigene Fans im Stadion sind.
Und da haben sie wirklich paar so Kandidaten. Also Belinkovic Savic, auch Parolo, der kommt zwar auch mal über den Biss, aber ist auch einer, der mal die Schultern hängen lässt. Auch ein Luis Alberto. Aber ja, richtige Beobachtung, finde ich auf jeden Fall. Also ich bin eigentlich kein Freund davon, alles an Körpersprache festzumachen, aber es ist natürlich schon ab und an ein Indikator. Und wenn du paar so zweifelhafte Mentalitäten auf dem Platz hast.
Oder es zumindest so scheint. Ich meine, wir kennen die ja nicht persönlich, aber es hat einen sportlichen Effekt. Allerdings muss man dazu auch sagen, dass man jetzt auf Tabellenplatz acht liegt, hat auch wesentlich damit zu tun, die letzten beiden Spiele in der Liga waren gegen Napoli 1 zu 2 verloren und gegen Juve 1 zu 2 verloren.
Und gegen Juve haben sie sich eigentlich wirklich sehr gut verkauft, muss man sagen.
Genau, und vorher stand man in der Tabelle auch noch besser da. Jetzt kommt dann Fro Sinone. Da hast du ja schon vorhin gesagt, die muss man...
Empoli auch. Genua ist nicht ganz so schlecht.
Also da könnte sich jetzt eben auch noch was drehen. Aber wir wollen es ja nicht nur an der Tabelle festmachen. Ganz kurz noch, als letztes würde ich gerne über den FC Bologna mit dir sprechen, weil Pippo Inzaghi da gefeuert wurde. Der Trainer vom FC Bologna, falls jetzt manche von euch da draußen gedacht haben, zockt da immer noch auf und erschießt wie aus dem Nichts das 1 zu 0 in der 90. Ich meine, die stehen auf Tabellenplatz 18. Das ist in der 20. Liga der erste Abstiegsplatz. Drei Punkte sind es jetzt nach vorne. Und vor allem die Zahl, die mich da erschreckt, ist, wir haben mit Frosinone einen Aussteiger, bei dem eigentlich alle davon ausgehen, okay, das wird schwierig. Und so sieht es auch bei Frosinone aus. Mit Kiewer Werona, einen, der, glaube ich, letzte Saison aufgestiegen ist. Und jetzt quasi so das verflixte zweite Jahr acht Punkte fürchterlich nach 21 Spielen.
Ich glaube, drei Punkte weggezogen.
Genau, richtig, das kommt ja noch genau mit dazu. Und dann eben Bologna mit 16 Toren nach 21 Spielen.
Ich glaube, der wollte zu schnell zu viel. Vielleicht wollte er auch endlich Erstligatrainer sein. War davor bei Venezia, ist da in den Aufstiegsplayoffs gescheitert. Hat mich dann auch sehr überrascht, dass er dann da hingeschmissen hat, beziehungsweise im Ruf aus Bologna gefolgt ist. Bologna war die Jahre davor, aber auch unter Donadoni schon so eine Mannschaft, die sich immer zwischen zehn und vierzehn eingependelt hat. Auch mal gerne dann irgendwie dann kurz mit Abstiegskampf zu tun hatte. Drei Spiele gewonnen, dann war man wieder Zehnther und dann hat man die letzten acht Spiele gar nicht mehr richtig gut gespielt. Aber eigentlich eine Mannschaft, die, glaube ich, den Anspruch hat, auch vom Namen her und Historie und Background eben zumindest immer einstellig zu spielen. Ich glaube, das war kein guter erster Serie A-Posten für Pippo Inzaghi, weil Bologna in den letzten Jahren auch vom Kader her so eine Mannschaft, dass du sagst, die müssen nicht einstellig sein, aber sie wollen halt unbedingt. Und wenn du dann in so einen Strudel reinkommst, aber ich muss sie schon sehr leiern, weil ich sie sehr wenig gesehen habe dieses Jahr.
Ich wollte es auch nicht mit dir über den abkickenden Sechser und wie die Entdeckungsschatten so einsetzen.
Aber ich glaube einfach, dass er da vielleicht noch mal ein Jahr anläuft mit Venezia Aufstieg oder so. Und das ist dann glaube ich auch leichter, wenn du mit deinem eigenen Team aufsteigst. Dann ist vielleicht eher die Chance, dass du auch die Saison überlebst, auch wenn du wieder absteigst, als mit einem Traditionsclub wie Bologna, wo die Ansprüche höher sind, als sie eigentlich sein sollten. Und du dann noch mit so einem Namen kommst, dass dein kleiner Bruder erfolgreicher Trainer ist. Ich habe keinen Bruder, der mir auf meinem Ebene Konkurrenz macht. Ich weiß nicht, wie sich das anfühlt.
Das war auf jeden Fall eine Herausforderung.
Vorbei wahrscheinlich, wenn du in der Erstligist anrufst und sagst, willst du bei uns Trainer sein, musst du auch wahrscheinlich viel gut zureden, dass du da nein sagst.
Ja klar, das hätte ja auch funktionieren können. Das hat ja auch damit zu tun, dass mit Parma Kaiciu, einer der Aufsteiger, sehr gut performt. Also 14 Punkte vor dem ersten Abstiegsplatz nach 21 Spieltagen. Die spielen eine richtig gute Runde bisher. Und das merkst du ja dann immer, wenn ein paar Vereine ein bisschen über ihren Verhältnissen spielen, ohne das Böse mein zu wollen, dann muss es ja ein paar andere unten auch reindrücken. Und da gehört auch das Bologna mit dazu. Spall auch, genau stimmt. Gut, ich könnte noch ewig mit dir über alle Vereine sprechen.
Ich glaube ich nicht. Ich habe noch nicht alle gehabt diese Saison.
Stell dein Licht mal nicht unter den Scheffel. Aber ich finde, das war grandios, dich nach fünf Jahren in den Brasenfunk zu haben. Unglaublich. Na, viereinhalb. Das wollen wir mal nicht aufrunden.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Viereinhalb Wochen. Also wir machen das definitiv wieder. Majo Rika von The Zone at Remedem auf Twitter verfolgt ihn da. Ihr könnt ihm auch bei Instagram folgen. Dann könnt ihr ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen blicken bei The Zone. Und weißt du schon, welches Spiel du jetzt als nächstes machen wirst?
Es ist ein Freitagsspiel. Es ist die Roma gegen Kiwo. Es ist an diesem Spieltag sogar keins. Das Wochenende frei. Ich fahr zum rumreichen SV Werder nach Nürnberg, wo wir Aufbaugegner spielen werden. Und die Woche drauf bin ich wieder im Einsatz.
Du glaubst, Werder wird Aufbaugegner gegen Nürnberg sein? Wie viel von Nürnberg hast du gesehen dieses Jahr? Wenn, dann werdet ihr ein sehr, sehr guter Aufbaugegner. Aber da kann ich jetzt doch vollen Brustton der Überzeugung sagen, weil ich da wirklich tief im Thema drin bin. Egal, was die machen, 4-1, 4-1, 4-4, 2, ne. Also wenn Werder das nicht gewinnt, dann würde ich nie wieder was von Europa-Pokal in dieser Saison hören.
Okay, dann gehe ich doch mit einem guten Gefühl hier noch raus.
Ja, siehst du, das freut mich. Und ich hoffe, ihr hören auch. Danke dir, Mario, komm mal wieder. Und euch lieben Hörern und Hörern, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war schon der zweite Kurzpass diese Woche. Das heißt, falls ihr den letzten noch gar nicht gehört habt, könnt ihr das noch nachholen. Wir haben über den 1. FC Kaisers Lautern gesprochen. Ja, auch die dritte Liga soll natürlich im Rasenfunk stattfinden. Die nächste Schlusskonferenz gibt's in der Super Bowl Edition in der Nacht auf Montag. Und dann gibt's noch ein Tribüngespräch in der nächsten Woche, auf das ich mich schon die ganzen letzten Tage vorbereitet habe und mich sehr drauf freue. Ich hoffe, euch gefällt's dann auch. Habt eine gute Zeit, bis bald, ciao!